hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast breast cancer as a global
disease are we up for the challenge
presented by dr. Benjamin Anderson
professor of surgery in the division of
general surgery surgical oncology
section at University of Washington
School of Medicine
I'm dr. Susie Valdez lab reports and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab Rhodes the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we again I remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type the questions into that
drop-down box that appear on that screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have any
trouble similar hearing this
presentation just click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having some trouble this presentation is
educational and that's offered
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
threads tab located in the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process for attaining those
credits please join me now in welcoming
our presenter today dr. Benjamin
Anderson
I will never 20 presentation or calling
dr. Anderson thank you very much Susie
I'm very pleased to be able to speak
with you today and to make this
presentation
what we're going to be talking about
today is breast cancer as a global
health issue and breast cancer as a
global disease is in fact a major
challenge for us around the world and
there are opportunities but also
limitations in what can happen I'm
looking forward to providing information
to you about this new breast health
global initiative began in 2002 as a
joint ly sponsored project between the
Fred Hutchinson Cancer Research Center
and susan g komen for the Cure let's
begin by talking about global cancer
trends around the world actually the
differences in distribution of cancer
around the world do relate to economic
development at least in terms of the
cancers that are most common and least
common in the highest income countries a
breast cancer lung cancer colorectal
cancer and prostate cancer are the
majority of cancers that are diagnosed
it's important to remember that in
addition to causes of cancer there are
differences because of screening when we
screen we find more cancers when we go
to medium income countries there are
cancers that are associated with
infectious origin and environmental
origin particularly in the GI tract and
in low-income countries cervical cancer
is the most prominent disease that we
have seen historically but it's
important to recognize that these are
not fixed figures they're in fact
changing over time so in 2008 there were
twelve point seven million cases of
cancer this is predicted to rise to 22
million by the year 2030
and what you can see is that the there
are some cancers that will be increasing
and some cancers that are decreasing so
those cancers associated with infections
will be decreasing because we are in
fact doing better with them and we're
finding ways of avoiding the infections
that cause these disease processes on
the other hand those cancers associated
with reproductive dietary and hormonal
factors are increasing breast cancer is
one of those so the in terms of these
ideologies of these cancers the source
of the cancer does relate to what the
best treatment management strategies or
prevention management strategies would
be those cancers associated with
infections such as cervical cancer which
is associated with human papillomavirus
or liver cancer caused by hepatitis or
gastric cancer caused by h pylori
infection these are areas where
vaccination is a primary source of
management by preventing the cancer from
occurring in the first place this is a
very cost effective way of addressing
these cancers where treatment can be
very difficult so liver cancers are hard
to treat because the liver operations
are difficult and the effectiveness is
challenging even in high-income
environments answers associated with
behavior such as tobacco associated
cancers this is also an area where
prevention plays a primary role there is
no useful application of tobacco one of
the statements that's commonly made is
tobacco associated tobacco is one of the
products that when used as directed will
kill you and therefore prevention is a
primary role when therefore when we have
cancers where primary prevention is a
beneficial strategy that is where we
want to go but for cancers where primary
prevention does not explain the majority
of cancers and therefore is not a
benefit we have to go through a process
of really detection correct diagnosis
and treatment in order to improve
outcome when you look at the those
factors that are associated with breast
cancer the the risk factors for them are
in many ways areas that we are not able
to change the outcome or when perhaps
don't wish to change them so avoiding
alcohol avoiding hormone exposure of
waiting radiation these are areas that
is difficult to make major changes
having more lactation is helpful and
weight control is of course desirable
but the main limitation that breast
cancer is even with all of these risk
factors these only explained twenty to
thirty percent of the breast cancers
that are diagnosed today and so if
that's the case then what we are really
looking for our health care systems that
can address that cycle of early
detection diagnosis and treatment now
looking at the distribution of cancer
around the world for breast disease you
can see that the high-income countries
such as the US is where we see the
greatest incidence of breast cancer this
is in part related to screening because
when we look for the cancers we find
them when we look at breast cancer
mortality you can see that the two are
mirror images of each other so here is
incidence here is mortality it is the
same areas where incidence is lowest
that mortality is the highest and this
speaks to the benefit of early diagnosis
finding the cancers before they are very
advanced stage disease Emma graphics
screening is the one test that has been
shown to be reduced the mortality of
breast cancer and so we can attribute
about 23% benefit in terms of overall
mortality reduction to rest cancer by
virtue of the use of screening well
there certainly is controversy about
mammographic screening is it possible
the areas where we're doing this too
much are there areas where we're
actually over diagnosing breast cancer
this goes beyond the scope of today's
talk
but overall the great majority of
experts around the world agreed that
there is a approximately 20% mortality
benefit to mammographic screening at a
minute
for women ages 50 to 65 when we started
screening you'll see that it changes the
distribution of these cancers in ways
that one might not have predicted
so mammographic screening really got
going in the US and the early 1980s
because the hip trials in the 1970s
showed this mortality benefit what we
saw in the u.s. was rising rates of
early stage cancer the node-negative
cancers and non invasive ductal
carcinoma in situ denote positive
cancers they more advanced cancers it
was assumed that the rate of those node
positive cancers would drop when the
incidence when screening got going we in
fact did not see that the more advanced
cancers remained at approximately the
same level this suggests that there may
be a difference where some cancers are
amenable to early diagnosis while others
are going to be biologically aggressive
regardless of the timing of their
diagnosis that's where treatment plays a
critical role what we did see in the
u.s. about eight years after screening
started to go it's we started to see a
drop in breast cancer mortality
beginning in approximately 1990 it's
been dropping by one to two percent per
year since then and overall we now have
a thirty five percent decrease in breast
cancer mortality in the u.s. in
comparison in 1990 so while we may have
controversy about screening it's hard to
explain the benefit and those outcomes
without attributing screening to be
playing a role in this so early
detection is essential to approve
outcome I think our evidence is clearing
this regard but it only works when it is
followed by appropriate breast cancer
treatment
so actually to save lives screening must
be linked to timely effective treatment
it's not really detection that saves
lives it's early treatment that saves
lives what you can see on this graph is
that with modeling it's the combination
of screening and treatment that creates
the outcomes
we want to see both in the US and around
the world but when you look at the
patterns in different countries you can
see overall this rising incidence of
cancer particularly in high-income
countries but also middle and low-income
countries there was a peak that occurred
around not 2000 that has leveled off in
high income countries presumably because
we've to a certain degree saturated
ourselves with that screening
middle-income countries such as those in
Latin America here exemplified by
Colombia and Costa Rica also seeing a
rising rate of breast cancer when the
screening has just been getting
established in these areas so that's
part of this but also people are living
longer this is true in low-income
countries such as Africa now what you
can see here is that in the high-income
countries
breast cancer mortality has been
dropping and some have argued well that
must be just related to treatment
perhaps that's just because they're
wealthy and therefore treatment is
provided but you will note that and
while while in middle-income countries
we've not seen the same mortality
benefit that has occurred in the
high-income regions but you will notice
that there are high-income countries
where we have not yet seen that drop in
breast cancer mortality these are same
countries in this case here Singapore
Japan in Korea where mammographic
screening has not taken off in the same
way that it has in the US and European
countries there we need to learn more
about it but again it does speak to the
potential value of mammographic
screening globally but we have an issue
in terms of trying to address cancer
that's because around the world the the
amount of funding going to cancer is
really been inadequate so here you can
see that while four point eight million
deaths result blow belief from cancer a
much lower amount of funding is direct
important cancer comparison to
infectious diseases including HIV TB and
malaria and so we have an inequity in
terms of how cancer is funded that is
needy
needs to be addressed the United Nations
has led the way beginning in 2011 with a
high-level meeting that showed us that
they want to redirect the World Health
Organization to begin to talk not just
about infectious diseases but also about
non communicable diseases called NCDs
and it's the NCDs
where the direction for w-h-o is now
going the NCDs include heart disease
lung disease diabetes and cancer and so
that is provided a new direction for us
but we have to recognize that resources
are limited and we therefore have to
adapt what we do looking at total
national health expenditure per capita
this ranges from $22 per person per year
in low-income countries to over four
thousand dollars per person i income
countries
so we cannot realistically just apply
the same approaches that we use in
high-income countries to regions that
have less funds to distribute the Breast
Health Global Initiative formed for the
purposes of starting to address how
would we manage breast cancer in these
limited resource environments expert
panels were pulled together in order to
create consensus opinion and to publish
outcomes he held two global summits in
2002 and 2005 and created what we'll
talk about in a minute the concept of
resource stratification we had two
summits where we then talked about
implementation and healthcare delivery
and the last global summit until the
present 2012 and Vienna was about
supportive care and quality of life and
the core concept that was advanced in
these global summits is this idea of
resource stratification that resources
that are applied to cancer management
vary in their relative necessity basic
level resources we defined as those that
are core resources without which one
cannot anticipate improvement in outcome
so breast cancer surgery
an example of this we do not have a way
to cure breast cancer today that does
not involve removal of the primary tumor
limited level resources the second tier
were those resources that one would
anticipate based upon high level
evidence would it make major
improvements in survival so most of our
treatment strategies such as drug
therapies chemotherapy endocrine therapy
in that category we created a third
level called enhanced level resources
these are services that may be very
valuable and helpful but may or may not
improve survival so for example
performing breast conservation therapy
that means a lumpectomy and radiation
this will improve outcome this will not
improve survival in comparison to
mastectomy its equal in terms of overall
cure but it does make the therapy much
more acceptable so there may be better
participation by women when they are
able to preserve the breast in
comparison to when they are lose it and
then there's some resources that
actually would are of lower priority
because they're very expensive and may
not improve on outcome such as PET scans
or breast MRI we may use these a lot in
high-income countries but if you ask how
many women do better by virtue of
getting a better picture of the breast
the answer is zero and that's because we
already know that removing the entire
breast is not better than doing breast
conserving therapy but it's important to
know what not to do in comparison to
what to view and so these tables health
care systems early detection diagnosis
and treatment by stage these are the
four levels of standard resources that
were laid out in the BH gi guidelines
first published in 2005 so in terms of
early detection what are those basic
level resources
well that's taking a history and
performing clinical examination
diagnostic imaging actually comes before
screening so in particular the use of
breast ultrasound this is very helpful
for the evaluation of breast masses by
getting a better image of
what we feel on the breast we actually
may be able to avoid biopsies and
mammographic screening this is the first
point but probably within limited
populations or target groups it's the
annual screening or every other year
screening is at the enhanced level and
that's because of the resources that are
required there are many things that need
to be set up before mammographic
screening is realistic in treatment what
would be basic well performing a
modified radical mastectomy and standard
systemic therapy for locally advanced
cancers chemotherapy endocrine therapy
these are those resources where one
begins consider this example from
Vietnam back in 2011 this was the cave
hospital in Hanoi this was the cancer
facility that was available when we
visited this area what we saw was that
on the right this is a standard room
that where patients were located there
are four beds in that room and there
were two or three patients per bed and
this is actually not what our Vietnamese
colleagues were focused on they did not
recognize this as a fundamental
limitation what they didn't want us to
see was the molecular pathology unit
that they had recently opened and they
were very excited and very
understandable but when you asked what
are how is this going to help actually
that was not clear to her Vietnamese
colleagues so this is an example of
where the resources and the perceived
need for resources were different I'm in
no way being critical of our Vietnamese
colleagues actually molecular pathology
is precisely what we talk about the most
in high-income countries but one must
have a prioritization before those rows
become relevant I will tell you that
things are much different today in
Vietnam the Cape Hospital is recently
being rebuilt progress is being made
around the world now the National
Comprehensive Cancer Network NCCN is now
adopt and resource stratification within
their guidelines these are the most
commonly
guidelines for cancer around the world
now they have created resource
stratification to cover over 75% of
cancers around the world
breast cancer is among them and they
used a system based upon a Breast Health
Global Initiative approach modified to
use in the NCCN framework the idea is
that using different levels of resources
that we can identify what should be done
or what is not necessarily to be done
depending on resource limitations in
addition it was recognized that there
are some interventions that might be
done based upon low-level resources that
we might not do at the high level today
here is the enhanced level guideline for
breast cancer by NCCN and what you can
see is that breast MRI and PET scans are
not being used in that that environment
when we go to the core level core level
is the same as what we termed limited in
BH GI this is where we start to see the
use of tools that are less expensive but
can achieve reasonable outcome so in
place of CT scans the use of chest
x-rays Domino ultrasound and plain films
can be used in place and in fact was
what we used back in the US before CT
scans were available at the most basic
level we see the minimum use of of the
of resources so for example her2 new
testing would not be appropriate either
at the basic or at the core level and
that's because trastuzumab the therapy
that is associated with her2/neu testing
is also not available so when we look at
those basic level resources what do we
see we see basic diagnostic workups and
that are available the World Health
Organization has been the global leader
in health management and the w-h-o
actually has been now adopted resource
stratification within their own
framework last year 2017 a cancer
prevention
control initiative was adopted and what
you will see here is that they have now
stated that the director general of
w-h-o should develop or adapt step wise
and research stratified guidance and
toolkits for addressing cancer and we
were really thrilled to see that w-h-o
now also is using this resource
stratification approach but in order to
apply these approaches one needs to know
what is in existence at present and so
situation analyses are a core value we
did a a project in Mexico the Latin
American early detection initiative for
breast cancer called Lady Baraka in
which we evaluated in conjunction with
incan which is the National Cancer
Institute of Mexico City the fundamental
resources for screening the healthcare
system had adopted mammographic
screening the question was is this going
to work the purpose of these this
analysis was to identify gaps and
barriers barriers were identified both
in terms of awareness education it was
shown that knowledge about self-care
increased likelihood of having a
mammogram by over two fold and that also
was associated with increased likelihood
of early diagnosis the concept was to do
remote screening using telomere MOG Rafi
but there were issues that had not been
recognized for example internet adequacy
is a problem bandwidth is an issue when
one is trying to send images and so the
in addition the use of the by rad system
where one rates the mammogram according
to the by red scale 1 to 5 and then
obtains a biopsy or aspect of by rads is
that the radiologist needs to know what
happens after that biopsies perform was
it cancer was it not cancer that
feedback had not been established so
recognizing this is an important step to
initial intervention
now for in the staging of cancer in the
US and in Europe
90% of cancers are early-stage zero one
or two by contrast in India over
three-quarters of cancers present as
locally advanced or metastatic disease
as a result we recognize that in the
setting of India it's difficult to
improve an outcome because even with all
the resources available it's hard to
make major shifts in breast cancer
mortality in the setting of stage 3 and
stage 4 cancer when we talk about
advanced stage cancer this is really
problematic the next picture is
difficult to look at but is in fact the
reality of the world this is these are
photographs of breast cancer provided to
us by dr. Peter bird who is a breast
cancer surgeon in Kenya and this is
commonly what he sees in his clinic it
illustrates why mammographic screening
is not the beginning point in
sub-saharan Africa because if you can
see the cancer from across the room you
most certainly do not need an imaging
test to amplify that ability to diagnose
it it's not the beginning point when we
started our work one of the critiques we
received was that some countries are so
poor that breast cancer is just not a
significant problem at least that was
the assertion but that does lead to a
question at what point our resource is
so limited in competing demands so great
the breast care programs make no sense
to create we went to Ghana in 2004 to
try to address this issue
Oh Ghana in western Africa is now a
lower middle-income country at that time
it was a low-income country this is the
confit anoche Teaching Hospital it is
the it is associated with the medical
school there is a nursing school and a
dental school and this was the breast
clinic where women came to have their
breast health issues I evaluated this
picture was the earliest age cancer that
I saw you will note that the patient's
left breast is higher
than her right and that's because of the
ten centimeter mass that the clinician
could feel in the breast on clinical
breast exam it was much more common with
this presentation the ulcerated tumor
and this is a setting where palliative
cares really the best that one could
hope for this is an example of a patient
who had a modified radical mastectomy
but now clearly has a bad axillary
recurrence this is a terrible health
issue and the point is that we need to
address the cancers in ways that are
with effective therapy it was not
effective in this patient space when we
asked patients why do you not come to
the hospital we found that there were
beliefs that were major obstacles such
as cancer isn't variably fatal why would
you go to the hospital if they were just
going to tell you we're going to die
there also were social misconceptions
such that a woman might have been doing
something wrong in order to create here
breast cancer that it's not true but
nonetheless was believed and then they
would also say why would you go to the
hospital they'll just cut off your
breast and you'll be dead in two years
and in fact the system was making this
true and that's because at that time
women would show up at the hospital they
would receive a mastectomy for they
locally advanced disease but they would
not receive either radiation or drug
therapy it is predictable that if we
perform a mastectomy but do not treat
with adjuvant therapy it is very likely
to recur with advanced stage disease and
therefore the system was making this
belief true that's a problem in addition
there are competing healthcare
environments this is a billboard you can
see that in the upper right this is a
they you go to the herbal clinic and
they claim they were treating breast
cancer and so because of this competing
health care system this is where
patients typically went first leading to
delays and diagnosis
here we saw the the multidisciplinary
clinic the gentleman in the front was
the one pathologist for that thousand
Bennett Hospital the lady to his right
was the one radiologist for the same
facility what we found was is obstacles
within the system patients for
preventing with advanced stage disease
they were receiving mastectomy 'z
without adjuvant treatment but when we
looked at what that one pathologist was
able to do for that thousand bed
hospital what was very common was that
pathology reports would take four to six
months to generate that is an example of
a basic level resource if you cannot
prove that something is cancer within
four to six months you cannot anticipate
major improvements in out now doctor
before alwah was the radiation
oncologist head of the cancer clinic now
head of the hospital in Ghana he and dr.
Helga stalsberg was a pathologist who
met at the Global Summit in 2005 dr.
stalsberg suggested that they could make
major improvements in outcome by virtue
of a training program and so they set up
a program where pathologists of which
there were an inadequate number in Ghana
would go to Norway and have special
training slots set up so this was not
costly it was just creating an
opportunity for them to learn they also
trained the technicians which was
critical and what they found was that
within 14 months they could have a
histopathology laboratory up and running
in the same facility so the point here
is that just putting money into systems
is not necessarily the outcome of course
resources are needed but often it's a
matter of organizing the system in ways
that are effective last year we
performed a situation analysis with the
minister of hit Ministry of Health in
Tanzania and the Susan G Komen
Foundation this was appropriate in
Tanzania as the ministry was recognizing
because breast cancer was rising at
the same time that cervical cancer was
decreasing and life expectancy was
increasing meaning that more women are
going to be living into the years where
breast cancer is going to be the
dominant cancer problem
so in Tanzania which is in eastern
Africa we visited different sites and we
learned about their health care system
this is a report that is now available
online so in this organized system going
from the primary health clinics at the
bottom of the pyramid
that's where patients first present they
progress to the district regional zonal
hospitals ultimately receiving treatment
at the national hospitals what we
learned was that while patients
presented initially with that primary
care level the initial diagnostic biopsy
was not available until level four and
that means that women would have to go
first to the district then to the
regional then to the zonal Hospital
before they could even get a biopsy so
as you can imagine very fewer women
would make it through the system and as
a result if they so it's in essence a
filter where only the women with the
most advanced stage disease would end up
getting diagnosed only those were the
most miserable problems would make their
way through and that is the major
limitation either one needs to make
needle biopsy available at a lower level
or you need to provide direct
connections from the primary care center
to the zonal hospital today the Ministry
of Health is working on making needle
biopsies available at the regional
hospitals and creating direct referral
from the primary care level setting to
make this system work but how in fact
are we going to implement these changes
how can we make this happen in realistic
fashion breast cancer initiative 2.5 is
a global campaign to reduce disparities
in breast cancer outcome for 2.5 million
women by the year 2025 or 2030 in
alignment
w-h-o goals so a group of organizations
as you can see here came together
including the Breast Health Global
Initiative to try to address these
outcomes because at the system level
this is more than what we as clinicians
think about so we talked about the
hospital but tend to forget about the
other groups that actually are critical
to our outcome so it's the government
it's the ministries where your decisions
are made this is where allocation of
resources takes place so while we might
think that the healthcare minister that
is the core issue actually it's the
finance minister
it's those are the people who actually
allocate those resources and it is civil
society it's the patients it's the
advocates these are the folks that drive
the changes so we have to be able to
communicate among these three groups
with the same language even though we
live in three different worlds the BCI
2.5 created what we call globe AM which
is a a data resource that is available
online and is currently being updated
you can go online you can identify
individual countries and download
existing data from w-h-o and the World
Bank about resources that are currently
available and about the current
presentation of cancer and by the by
taking this data you can perform
comparisons between different countries
to see where resources are available we
also created a set of knowledge
summaries these knowledge summaries
provide that core information about
planning health care prevention early
detection treatment following WH OHS
pathways and what we put together in
these documents in addition to the
clinical component are the policy
components that go with this this is
important because policymakers often are
not medically trained and certainly are
not going to spend the time to
understand our kaplan-meier curves they
need to know what are the key issues
that need
be addressed similarly our advocates and
civil society needs to know what is
appropriate for bringing in so the idea
of going and advocating for mammographic
screening in an environment where women
are presenting with cancers that are
visible that is not the next step we
created we have created these situation
analysis tools so that we can survey
what resources are available and in
addition we recently published a model
that can help communicate to ministries
the idea of course is that when we have
cancer there is a point at which it is
diagnosed and death will result in those
cancers that are not treated when we
provide treatment this prolongs survival
and cures some patients when we then add
early diagnosis to this through
screening we see further improvements
beyond that this is the conceptual
framework which is not adequate to speak
to healthcare ministers that need to
make rapid decisions about resources
they need to understand how much of the
benefit might be attributable to this so
you're in the example of Tanzania we
have the current standard today that
which relates to mortality after five
years and what are this intervention
shows that as we introduce screening and
down stage disease as we add therapies
that we can see gradual improvements in
outcomes so the blue bars are when
endocrine therapy alone is available the
red bars are went both end up in therapy
and chemotherapy are available and this
can be shown in terms of what years of
life saved after five years a minister
will understand this data well these are
the people this is their population
these are voters so understanding this
is essential in communicating and this
is what led us to this concept of phased
implementation the idea of going through
steps in order to make improvements in
outcome you have to go in stepwise
fashion and you have to be
to measure your outcomes in order to
make this difference public's last year
in Lancet Oncology is this phased
implementation approach as applied in
Peru so Peru is a middle-income country
in Latin America and the idea here is
recognizing that the healthcare systems
are different from what we typically
think about first we need to have
standard guidelines and protocols and we
need to have a trained healthcare
workforce so using resource
stratification such as NCCN is a good
stepping point but we need educational
materials providers that have never seen
early stage cancer will likely not
recognize it someone might say well
that's not breast cancer it's not all
serrated of course that that's a lack of
education to providers that working up
palpable lumps is appropriate and
necessary training about how to perform
clinical examination is a necessary step
these gentlemen are learning fine needle
aspiration which is a an affordable
technique for evaluating tissue and so
developing systems where patients are
triage is critical just like in the
Tanzania example we in high-income
countries tend to assume that the
resources and locations are available as
if the patient lived next door to the
Cancer Center when in fact the Cancer
Center may be hours away from where they
live and not that many patients are
going to go so path led a program where
the clinical breast examination and
community at education occurred in the
primary level initial tissue sampling
with finding the laceration was
performed at the local hospital which is
accessible and it was fna that was used
to decide who needed to go to the Cancer
Center versus who is not so that this is
actually a triage approach which is
essential to functional healthcare
systems now find me laceration there's
controversy about its use it used to be
highly used in the u.s. now
most centers do not use fna but instead
use core needle biopsy the problem with
core needle biopsy is it's very
expensive relatively speaking the
needles cost thirty to sixty dollars and
they should be single-use by contrast
fine needle aspiration can be performed
with about a five dollar charge when you
look at the cost of the class slides and
the needles but particularly relevant if
the person who is performing the fna can
read it one can get essentially an
immediate result and the patient could
receive triage they do not need to wait
a day or two to find out what those
results show which if you traveled many
hours to get to this place you might not
be able to stay that period of time but
a limitation of fna it requires experts
cytologic input but are the two tools
competitive no they're not they can be
used in different settings and in fact
fna is a triage tool is a different
question for F then F n/a for tissue
sampling for core needle biopsy so how
then do we adapt these resources in ways
that are effective we need to consider
these approaches for scaling up so we
might develop this model but then we
have to be able to expand it in ways
that are useful at a country level here
in Peru you see educational programs
this is a nurse midwife providing
education about a basic breast health
and there the goal is to scale this up
also considering the use of special
tools such as ultrasound ultrasound can
both improve diagnostic input and can
limit the number of woman's that may
need to go a simple cyst something that
does not require further workup so in
that path model creating a program that
can be scaled up at the national level
that is a core value next week we will
be operating the breast health Global
Initiative our sixth global summit and
it is going to focus on this phased
implementation our first day will be on
phased implementation for early
detection day two will focus on phase
implementation for treatment and they
three will focus on integration within
existing healthcare systems so when we
see diseases as competitive gosh I'm a
breast cancer person which means I'm not
an HIV person both diseases lose and in
when we have that frame of that frame of
mind when in fact it is a shared
infrastructure that makes both of them
work that's how we're going to make so
finally I'd like to talk about
implementation research this is how do
we make a difference in implementation
by virtue of studying its applications
alum BIA
a national education a national early
detection program was adopted in the
early 2000s but the problem was that it
was not being implemented so although it
was stated that all women 50 to 65
should have a mammogram at least every
two years this was not in fact taking
place and so that we performed they
performed a cluster randomized trial
where in clinics there was an
intervention that the intervention was
on the clinic they provided training and
education about screening how it is done
well its value and then they followed to
see how this compared to the control
group where there was no specific
intervention that was performed at that
time fewer than 20% of women in the
court age group when they came to the
facility were offered mammographic
screening what you can see here is that
in the intervention group there were the
number of cancers was increased relative
to those patients who were in the
control group where more there were
fewer cancers found and more were
advanced stage when it was the following
year that in the intervention group
fewer cancers were found presumably
because they had been aisle were already
fighted earlier stage where more cancers
were found in the intervention in the
non intervention control group but at a
later point a outcome that was not
anticipated was that in fact more women
successfully had breast conservation by
virtue of that early diagnosis so the
point here is that when we introduce
screening not only in kin screening
improve outcome in terms of stage at
diagnosis but we may be able to conserve
the breast more often which makes the
intervention more acceptable this is the
sort of thing that we can study well in
the setting of implementation research
here is a study that the Breast Health
Global Initiative health support in
Indonesia the idea was that nurse
midwives and volunteers were trained in
clinical breast examination women then
came to the facility and received both a
clinical exam and a mammogram and
results were compared of 1179 women went
underwent both mammographic screening
and clinical breast exam approximately
one quarter of them needed a diagnostic
workup
it is often underappreciated that when
we do screening a significant fraction
of women will need a workup even though
it is a small minority that will end up
having cancers in fact 14 cancers were
found about 1.2 percent which is about
one what one expects in mammographic
screening but of importance in Indonesia
of the 14 cancers that were found 13
could be pre appreciated on clinical
breast exam now this does not mean the
mammogram mammography is unimportant
that even though in that setting it only
added one patient the point here is that
in the in an unscreened population
clinical breast exam is the point to
begin that is where we start but what
happened was that in follow-up eight of
never received treatment when we
investigated why two refused and
for laws to follow up so the point here
is one needs to be certain that the
system is going to function and those
patients that are screen will follow
through to have treatment that's
available now what do we know about
clinical exam actually in the early
trials 60% of cancers could be found
initially on clinical exam there are
some cancers that appreciated on
clinical exam that are not seen on
mammograms particularly in dense breasts
so clinical breast exam just is
necessary whether or not it improves
outcome in terms of survival there is a
trial going on in India in which women
are being randomized to clinical breast
exam versus control follow-up and what
we're seeing in the early stages of this
trial after three cycles we can see that
the early stage disease is becoming more
common in those women who undergo
clinical breast exam while the incidence
of the advanced stage disease is not
changing that's the lower-left
graphs mortality has not shifted in
India by virtue this yet but it may be
that this is a matter of time you will
know this pattern looks very similar to
the pattern for screening mammography as
we saw in the early trials not all of
the mammography trials showed survival
benefit this is the Canadian trial which
is the most commonly cited source for
those that question the value of
mammographic screening because when
clinical when screening was started in
Canada they they in these trials the
overall survival was the same with 25
years of follow-up this has led some to
criticize the Canadians and questioned
whether their mammography quality was
good or whether there was a selection
bias in terms of how the trial was done
but what is often overlooked in the
trial was that in that control group the
women who did not receive mammographic
screening within the setting the median
tumor size was approximately 2
centimeters over the duration of the
this is very different from India or
sub-saharan Africa so I would suggest
the most interesting aspect of the
Canadian trial is not about whether they
were doing mammography well it's about
what were they doing in the control
group how did they get the tumor size
only two centimeters with clinical
examination alone because that's the
application for countries that cannot
afford mammographic screening we also
have to recognize that there are delays
in diagnosis so here we're looking at a
study performed by dr. Anya Romanov in
Peru every patient presenting to that
that Regional Cancer Center in the north
and saw a surgeon with a new cancer
diagnosis was surveyed outcomes as
related to delay and diagnosis was
evaluated and what you can see is that
there were patient delays meaning that
while the patient appreciated symptoms
on average over 200 days was between the
initial presentation that they
appreciated and that initial diagnostic
workup but further there was a delay in
the healthcare system by an even greater
amount between the initial presentation
to the initiation of treatment 241 days
of note 93 percent of the breast cancers
were self detected so while we might in
some settings we critiqued the value of
clinical examination in fact it's the
only tool and therefore we have to
recognize that it's our entry point as
imperfect as it might be with that
overall delay of 407 days they found
that the prior exposure prior use of
clinical breast exam at a significant
benefit so these are women that said
they someone had done a clinical breast
exam in the past and they found that
there were those patients who at some
point before it add a clinical exam at
less delay and work for more likely to
present with early stage
disease so we forget that clinical
breast exam has an educational component
by performing a clinical exam we're
helping women understand what it is that
we're looking for and that difference
that benefit and clinical exam persisted
even when controlling for economic level
and insurance source so it wasn't just
that they were in a better system so
clinical breast exam absolutely has
value in limited resource environments
and may have more value in high-end
combined environments than is recognized
based upon our randomized trials so
overall what we see here is that we're
dealing with systems we need to on the
healthcare side have early detection
diagnosis and treatment in a functional
way but in addition there is a public
side that needs to be performed as well
we need survivors because it is the
survivors that organize into advocacy
groups they are the ones that both
interface with the government and they
are the ones that create awareness it's
the advocates that create awareness that
help women understand why they should be
coming in it's not listening to your
physician that's the key it's listening
to survivors that is the key
therefore we need to understand social
beliefs this is the last study I'm going
to show you which is a study performed
by dr. role of Shaheen who is a
radiologist formerly at Harvard and now
in Toronto and what she was examining
was women in Gaza or Gaza and women
outside of the area it exposes a
important concept in terms of how women
believe about cancer so when these women
were surveyed over 90% were willing to
have a mammogram if they felt something
wrong in the breast that is if they had
a symptom they also believed that
survival would be improved if the cancer
was earlier in its diagnosis but if you
ask the women how many were willing to
have a screening mammogram meaning that
they felt nothing wrong but they were
gonna get this test actually now it was
minority that we're willing to to
participate and really when you think
about it in our health care system we
have our own belief system as well so we
tell women come in get a mammogram we're
going to get this picture of your
breasts even though you feel nothing
wrong then we're gonna tell you there's
something wrong with your breasts and
we're going to operate on you then we're
going to give you drugs that makes your
hair fall out then we're going to burn
your skin with radiation but great news
you'll be better after we do this it's
not hard to understand why someone from
a limited resource environment would say
that's crazy I feel fine
why would I come in and do those things
so we all have our belief systems
I do think ours is based on evidence but
that doesn't make it less of a belief
system so in summary cancer is
increasingly affecting countries at all
economic levels while the health care
investment is failing to match the
challenge research stratified guidelines
provide a framework for prioritizing
sustainable healthcare strategies these
baseline assessments are necessary to
determine steps for sequential
programmatic building those situation
analyses and then we use phased
implementation to define sustainable
approaches that integrate into existing
health care systems outcome ultimately
then implementation research is the
basis by which systematic improvements
can be measured I do believe that we
will be able to see a drop in breast
cancer mortality around the globe we
just have some serious work to do
between now and then thank you very much
for your attention and thank you dr. ben
they asked questions about how viewers
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of the presentation window
type your questions in the box
that appear in his screen you click the
symbol verse speakers will fall off with
you yet so let's take a look at our
question why is the average age of
breast cancer younger inside one Africa
that he uses well thank you for that
question Suzy actually there's we look
at cancer distribution and it is
commonly said in sub-saharan Africa and
in Latin America that this and parts of
Asia
the assertion is cancer must be
different biologically in these limited
resource environments and the reason
being it's argued that we see more women
diagnosed in their 40s than in in
high-income countries where the average
age is in the 50s however when you
consider the example of Tanzania you can
realize how the health care system is
actually making this true so when we do
not do screening screening is best at
finding cancers in women 50 to 65 that's
the area where it is a clearest benefit
there there are fewer cancers to find in
the 40s on average but if we do not do
screening and if we have a system like
Tanzania where only the women who are
having the biggest problems end up
getting a diagnosis then that that is a
selection process well who has the most
aggressive advanced disease it's the
young women with the triple negative
cancers that will ultimately have these
symptoms so actually when we introduce
screening the average age a breast
cancer diagnosis will rise and that and
that's it there is a epidemiological
result of a screening that is often not
appreciated thank you and dr. Anderson
our resource stratified guidelines
actually providing support for
substandard care so
that early on was the very criticism
that we received in writing these
guidelines people would say well you're
certifying substandard cares being
adequate that is not the concept of
resource stratification resource
stratification is about prioritizing how
to advance our systems in a an
appropriate way so instead of a fast
forwarding to mammographic screening
that would not be functional using
clinical exam is an initial step the
goal is to get all of these systems to
progress but you have to do it in an
organized stepwise fashion and this is
the framework for that setup thank you
for that and dr. Andersson one of our
viewers want to know what are the NCCN
harmonized harmonized guidelines and how
do they help care in low middle-income
countries so after NCCN did the resource
stratified guidelines for cancer he the
question became how do we use this and
so a special program that was a
collaboration between the NCCN the
American Cancer Society the Clinton
Health Foundation and IBM they organized
a group called the African consortium
for cancer where 12 different
sub-saharan African countries were
brought together and asked the question
how can would they like to use the NCCN
guidelines and what our African
colleagues said was we don't want a
whole set of guidelines we want a
guideline that we feel is appropriate
for our resources in sub-saharan Africa
and so through a series of meetings they
identified where they thought
sub-saharan Africa mapped in that basic
core and enhanced levels and that single
harmonized guideline or set of
guidelines is now available on the NCCM
website a similar project was done in
the Caribbean and those guidelines are
also available and it's very in
to compare where the Caribbean countries
thought they mapped versus where the
African countries act so the point is
that by using resource stratification
you can create opportunities for people
in region to develop their own
approaches that are not making mistakes
thank you and we have one final question
dr. Anderson how does breast cancer
present in underserved communities in
the u.s. so we like to think of the u.s.
as a homogeneous country where health
care is available and it's very clear
that actually health care is not
available to all that we have our own
settings and that there are underserved
communities where disease presents at
later stages and access to appropriate
treatment is much more limited our one
of my colleagues dr. Pat Morgan
previously worked at Memorial
sloan-kettering in the Upper East Side
of New York but his since moved to
mamonas Hospital in Brooklyn the point
that he makes is that when one looks at
the breast cancer distribution between
these two hospitals Memorial
sloan-kettering looks like our standard
high-income country settings whereas the
distribution of breast cancer in mamonas
in Brooklyn looks like a middle-income
country more Stage two and three less
Stage one that is crossing a river so
the idea that it's all Geographic no it
isn't it's about health care
distribution and we have to think about
how we to best address our limited
resource environments within the US as
well if we're going to see improvement
in the u.s. population health overall
thank you dr. Anderson thank you for
your important research would you like
to provide our viewers with some closing
remarks today
well I'm yes I I feel that we have so
many opportunities to improve an outcome
and right now we're in this debate in
the US about whether
we provide healthcare or not to the
general public and I think the belief
system that needs to be challenged is
this idea that we cannot afford health
care for all it at least in some basic
level resources and the idea that we
don't provide for prenatal vitamins and
but then we do pay for the premature
child that's financially unsound so we
need to recognize that it's actually
unaffordable to not provide health care
it's just we need to make smart
decisions about how to do this in ways
that are evidence-based well said dr.
Anderson thank you again for your
presentation and your research but also
like to thank elaborate or making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
2019 you'll receive an email from
laborat letting me know when the webcast
will be available for reflect we share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed the exhibit that's
all for now and thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye bye